we don't know a whole lot about
cyberpunk 2077 in fact we basically
don't know anything about CD projekt
red's next big RPG but if these new job
openings are any indication it sounds
like cyberpunk 2077 might feature
vehicles my name is Jake and I can't say
whether or not Androids Dream of
Electric Sheep but it sounds like they
might be able to pilot vehicles the
Polish studio is looking for a vehicle
gameplay programmer to create the whole
architecture of vehicle related code and
the physics of driving and flying in
those vehicles this isn't the only
vehicle related job at for cyberpunk
2077 as CD Projekt RED is also hiring a
vehicle gameplay designer to create
compelling vehicle based gameplay this
includes but is not limited to vehicle
handling and controls vehicle combat and
relevant vehicle based AI systems
another requisition also mentions
vehicles a successful candidate for a
concept artist position will create
technical concepts for vehicles machines
and weapons according to the post CD
Projekt RED appears to be on a hiring
spree for cyberpunk 2077 as it has more
than 60 open positions for the game
posted on its careers website most of
these jobs are located at the studio's
main headquarters in Warsaw the vehicle
related posts were discovered by all
games Delta and CG mag online cyberpunk
2077 is scheduled to launch sometime in
the 20 17 to 20 21 window if I were to
guess I'd say it's probably closer to
the 20 21 window so don't expect to see
more of it until CD Projekt RED can
prepare an impressive showcase for it
but when we do find out more you'll be
the first to know